[Musique]
et maintenant retrouvons une nouvelle
histoire de papi
grenierut enfants ça fait longtemps
qu'on s'est pas vu grand-père lève la
tête je suis là je reviens de la
préfecture là
ça fait vraiment longtemps qu'on s pas
vu [ __ ] bon écoute je te laisse les
gamin à plus tard ok grand papi grenier
coucou grand papi grand PAP les enfants
appelez-moi papi ça sent plus simple
pour les futures vidéos papi papi tu
nous racontes une histoire oh une
histoire est-ce que je vous ai raconté
la fois où j'étais le dis pas ça [ __ ]
où ils vont appeler les f vous êtes qui
je suis la voix dans ta tête qui
t'empêche de devenir fou c'est vrai
mercizvous va faire repérer non c'est
vrai chute bonjour une pizza TR fromages
rustique c'est bien ici non j'aime pas
les enchoix j'ai dit non bref est-ce que
je vous ai raconté la fois plôt où
j'étais le Jésus de l'ESPA c'était en
2007 c'était bien avant qu'electronicar
devienne une filiale du cartel de la
drogue tout a commencé dans une mission
de routine quand j'ai touché une balise
extraterrestre ce qui m'a fait avoir des
flashback étranges je comprenais pas ce
que ça voulait dire heureusement mon
équipage pouvait m'aider Shepard votre
race n'est pas assez avancé pour
comprendre ses
visions laissez-moi vous aider je vais
m'introduire dans votre esprit pour voir
votre
passé votre race n'est pas assez avancé
pour comprendre C vision je sais pas
merde concentrez-vous j'y suis je
vois c'est violent je vois quelque chose
de brutal c'est trouble mais non mais oh
mais attendez Shepard vous êtes en train
de vous faire cuire un grtin au fromage
moi j'étais le commandant c'est moi qui
décidait qu'est-ce qu'on faisait et où
que le vaisseau il devait aller
commandant lâchez ça vous faites
n'importe quoi com arrête fais ce que je
veux c'est moi qui décide on va dans le
soleil c'est pas vrai rendez-moi le
manche non non je crois que je vais
vomir PAP sois sérieux non ça va bref
après les recherches on a découvert
qu'une race de machine extrêmement ch à
montrer à l'image voulait détruire toute
vie dans la
galaxie nous somm les moonneurs vousriez
peur si notre nom França nétait pas
ricule tout ça c'était compliqué pour un
soldat comme moi au début noustions que
TR
moian pvrean on a rien pu faire pour
sauver jepard vous devez choisir entre
Hashley et kaidane vous pourrez pas
sauver les deux je dois choisir entre
kaidane
ou
ale commandant Shepard allez des kidan
moi ça va je suis pas en danger en fait
h
j'arrive allô c'est Kaidan je suis juste
à côté de vous j'ai tué tous les ennemis
vous venez me récupérer Dieu il a perdu
la tête c'est la fièvre Joker démarre le
vaisseau e oh e oh
petit bonhomme que personne n'a sauvé
petit bonhomme que tu as abandonné petit
bonhomme que tout le monde a oublié ce
petit bonhomme c'est
Kaidan écoutez-moi tous je sais que la
mort de Kaidan vous a bouleversé
Kaidan qui c'est c'est le mec là bon
laisse tomber mais n'oubliez pas nous
sommes une équipe tout au long de mes
aventures pour m'aider pendant toutes
ces batailles j'avais regroupé les
meilleurs équipiers possibles ils
avaient tous leur capacités leur
caractère je les oublierai jamais
évidemment plus jamais group
aprsus appelez-moi arangel c'est mon
pseudo sur origine une au pouvoir
biotiquea toutes les ont des pouvoirs
bioti mais non pas du tout alors les
pvoirs bioti c'est pas
[Rires]
automatique ce que j'aimis chez cétait
son sourire
sur fait je pas dans la vidé
par Gén
[Musique]
par les faire croise dans le vaau JIS le
adresser la parole parceon rien
àoutre normand
et vous savez ce que je me disais en
voyant tous ces
gens lesquels je vais pouvoir me taper
et après all Combre les Méch mais avant
ça on av d'autres missions plus
importantes à
faire une galaxie à sauveroute truc
super important ok je la nourriture pour
mes poissons rouges le hamster s'il vous
plaît chpard on vous attend sur le
Normandie écoutez Miranda je suis le
Commandant Shepard et cette boutique est
ma préférée de la citadelle et dire que
j'ai quitté mon peuple pour aider cet
[Applaudissements]
homme BL à part on en a vécu des choses
des combats des batailles spatiale et
j'étais toujours à la pointe de
l'attaque
FZ de ma gueule Shepard c'est en plein
milieu de la fusillade va là [ __ ]
Brutti on peut pendant toutes ces
aventures on a rencontré des paquets
d'ennemis tous plus dangereux les uns
que les autres trembler race organique
devant nous les moisneur nous allons
vous détruire avec notre armée les les
récolteurs oh [ __ ] pass le jeu en
anglais merde et aussi des alliés
vraiment pas très fiables bonjour je
suis là me trouble quoi qu'est-ce qu'il
a dit trouble vous avez compris quoi
quoi
[ __ ] finalement on a réussi à unir
toutes les races de la galaxie pour la
bataille finale et j'ai réussi à me
glisser à l'intérieur de la citadelle
c'était là où il y avait le point faible
de l'ennemi parce qu'ils sont sympas ils
avaient prévu trois points faibles au
cas où pour qu'on les tue en tout cas
c'était là où j'aurais l'occasion de
comprendre le but profond des
moissonneurs vous les races organique
vous construisez des robots qui un jour
vous
donc pour vous sauver la vie on préfère
vous tuer
avant bon ok dis comme ça ça a l'air
débile mais on y réfléchi super
longtemps le destin de l'humanité repose
sur toi et de ton choix défendre à la
fin tu peux choisir une de ces trois fin
la première est la fin contrôle est-ce
que vous êtes prêts à devenir un
moçonnaur la deuxième est la fin
synthèse votre âme devra fusionner avec
la stadelle la troisème est la fin
destruction qui mettra fin au cycle
qu'est-ce que vous allez choisir vous
êtes prêts maintenant 3 2 1 c'est à vous
àoite là milieu milieu milieu
milieu milieu
[Musique]
j'ai
par
jepard TF
[Musique]
je dois y
aller ça s passé exactement comme çaf en
tout cas jusquà la version EX mais PAP
c'est pas une histoire ça c'est un jeu
vidéo comment ça ça dire que est
toujours
en pap PAP tu nous racontes une autre
histoire oh bien sûr mais ça sera pour
la prochaine fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]